MARCO: OK.
Hi, everyone.
Thank you for
coming to this talk.
My name is Marco.
I'm a designer on Android.
I lead the design
team that works
on Google Play and the
core Android applications.
KIRILL: And I'm Kirill.
I'm a UI engineer on
the Google Play team,
working mostly on the Store app.
MARCO: Right, so
today, we're going
to be talking about Google Play.
Let's see how many people
use Google Play here,
just to make sure that
everybody knows what it is.
How many people use at least
one application in Google Play?
Right.
How many people use at least
two applications on Google Play?
Three applications?
The whole suite?
Great, we have some fans.
So for anyone who
didn't raise their hand,
Google Play is basically, in
practice, six applications
which they define the
media offering from Google.
It's the store where
you purchase content,
and it is a set of
applications where
you enjoy the content
you purchased or you
got for free, like books,
music, movies, magazines,
and news and games.
Today, we're going to talk
to you about a journey
that our team took
about a year ago
when we designed the Play
suite of applications.
We think this is a very
interesting journey,
because it talks about
some of the principles
that we've shown yesterday
during the keynote, which
is the One Adaptive Design.
Our experience was basically
around thinking about a system
that could scale
across all devices
and that could be
consistently perceived
as one suite-- as one
family of applications,
where iconography, colors,
how the content is displayed,
interaction, was
defined once to scale
across all devices in
different platforms.
This is how we should feel.
It is multiple devices.
In a sense, the UI is
scaling across them
in a very consistent
and familiar way,
where the interaction
doesn't change
and where the user
is not surprised.
There are problems that we face
today, where the experience is
almost more important to be
defined across all devices,
to be consistent, rather
than very specific for web
versus iOS versus Android.
Because we see users
scaling and moving
across all devices
in a very fluid way.
So this was Play in 2012.
As you can see, they were
a set of applications
not very consistent
with one another.
And if you went to the
web, we had even yet
another mental model,
another look and feel,
and another approach
to interaction.
The issues, in essence, were
the design wasn't consistent,
the design didn't
scale, and one size
couldn't fit all of our users.
Design wasn't consistent.
In essence, you see that even
the same content, like albums,
would be represented
differently from web
to devices to the store.
We just had a lot of
interaction models.
Design didn't scale.
Because we had different
design for web and devices,
we ended up having to design
the same feature multiple times.
And this was taking a lot
of time from design side,
where we had to be thinking
about the same feature,
about how it would behave and be
implemented from an interaction
design perspective
and visual design
perspective on web
versus devices.
And one size couldn't fit
all, because essentially, we
didn't have a way to
display content dynamically.
Especially on the store,
we had to draw tiles
manually to recommend
content to our users.
But we couldn't generate
content in a dynamic way
to suggest content that was
really personalized to people,
because there wasn't
a way to display it.
So our goals that we
set up for this project
were to create consistency
across Play applications,
to have efficient layouts
across device and web,
and to be able to populate
our content dynamically.
So where did we start?
We actually didn't start
by thinking about grids,
and we didn't start
thinking about the spaces
where the information
would live.
We rather started
thinking about the models
that we would use to
fill up our spaces.
So what was our key component?
Our key component was a card.
Back then, as today, Google
was embracing this metaphor.
And it felt for
us that if content
is what we display most of the
time in our Play applications,
a card felt like a very
good common denominator
to display these
types of objects.
It would be good to
display applications,
to display albums and movies
and magazines and books-- even
people or places.
You name it.
It was a very good
way to display objects
and to sort of have this
common denominator that
could make these
interactions across objects
consistent-- the way you
would remove objects,
the way you would add objects,
the way you would do actions
with objects, could be
consistent no matter what
these objects were and no
matter where they lived.
The second item-- the
second structural item--
that we thought about
were the canvases,
which essentially are
where these objects live.
A canvas is just a space,
and the [? gray ?] of Google
is the color E5E5E5, which
lives in many different places
of our applications.
What we did, we started defining
our space divided in columns,
so that the content could be
displayed in a similar fashion
and across a grid
that was defined
to scale across
multiple devices' width.
So the more the device was
large, the more content
we could display.
And you could have
less or more content.
It could be reordered.
The content was
basically a living object
into these canvases.
It could change
according to context.
It could be grouped in clusters,
as I'll show you later,
or into this big long
list or big long grids,
like in search result.
It could be content like movies.
It could be content like people.
We have this view in our
Play games application.
And a canvas didn't have to be,
necessarily, a gray background.
A canvas is essentially anything
that is living underneath.
In Play Movies, if you
played with this application,
we have an awesome
feature where basically,
when you pause the movie, we
identify who the actor is.
We also identify if there's a
song playing in the background.
And we tell the user.
So here, we identify the actor.
And you see, we show
a person's card,
and we show a bunch
of movies where
this actor has
been participating.
And we do it in the
same, consistent way.
The movie playing
is just a canvas
where our content is
displayed dynamically.
We do the same thing in books.
When we select a word and
this word is a location,
we identify that
being a location,
and we show the location card.
Even here, the
canvas is content.
The third item in
our list were sizes.
Obviously, a card that
looks of a certain size
on a phone-- the same size
will be perceived smaller
on bigger screens, simply
because the larger the canvas,
the more the size will
be perceived small,
versus the same size being
used on a smaller screen.
So this is a tiny
card which we use
on phone, which turns
into a small card which
we use on tablets.
And we started to find a bunch
of other different cards,
because the cards need to
adapt to different layouts that
need different characteristics,
like list views.
We also defined sizes because
we needed hierarchy, as well.
When we recommend
content, we like
to say this is very
special for you.
We make it very big.
And we like to say
these are maybe
other things you may
be interested about.
This could be smaller.
So sizes are super
important, and again,
while the sizes change, the
interaction doesn't change.
We always have those overflow
menus on those cards.
We always have the same way
we present this content.
You should almost feel like
the content is this card, which
is expanding and moving
and twisting around.
But it doesn't change.
It's the same card,
even in a list view.
Now, the other thing
were the clusters.
So for the psychology
of perception,
when I have multiple
items next to one another,
obviously they will
perceive that as a group.
And groups are important
to define areas
where the user should
interact, or also collections.
And you see here
where the hierarchy
is preserved when we have
big items and smaller items.
And you can also see that
when we defined the sizes,
we made sure they were part
of the same modular system,
so they could be plugged
into one another.
We also made sure that
these sizes would make sense
across all the devices we have.
They would make sense on phones.
They would make sense on
seven inch tablets, or 10 inch
tablets and beyond--
including the web.
Let's talk about
interaction now.
We have websites.
We have touchscreen devices.
We think that interaction
should be consistent.
The user shouldn't feel lost
when he goes between an Android
device to an iOS
device to the web.
Obviously, the web has a
different type of interaction,
because you use a
mouse most of the time.
But the pattern could
be still consistent.
So we use a side navigation,
which is hidden on devices.
You need to tap on what people
call the hamburger menu.
But on web, we actually
leave it exposed,
because we have more space.
Also, you see that
the navigation menu
provides the same
type of information.
However, we did make some
differences to make sure
that all the different
form factors could
be the most efficient
as possible.
So you see here,
playlist is exposed
as a single destination
on devices to the right.
But on the left and
web, the playlists
are exposed in the
side navigation itself,
so the user can drag
content into it,
and we can facilitate
a faster interaction.
Nevertheless, the positions
where you find your content,
where you navigate, is
consistent across web
and devices here.
Let's look at another
example-- the tabs.
If you're an Android
user, you know
that we have swipey tabs, so you
can swipe from one to another.
This doesn't happen on the web.
It would be very difficult
to swipe with the mouse.
But still, we have the same
information being displayed.
In this example to the
right-- or to my left--
I'm swiping to see genres
on touch screen devices.
On the web, I need to
select a particular item
and see a drop down list.
So the interaction is
slightly different,
but again, the
user will not feel
lost, because the positioning
of those elements is consistent.
We have menu buttons.
On the web, we expose
them on rollover.
This is the Play Music
experience on the web.
But on devices, we
expose menu buttons
at the single card level,
because we don't have rollover,
obviously.
On iOS, we'll have panels
that slide from the bottom,
because this is the
typical iOS pattern.
And we want to make
people feel at ease when
they use our applications.
On Android, we use
pop ups, because this
is how Android does.
Again, the interaction
is the same.
The expressions of
this interaction
may change slightly between
different platforms.
So let's look at the outcome.
These were our suite
of applications.
These are our suite
of applications today.
You see that the layouts
feel more consistent.
We have the menu item
on top of every card.
Everything is the
same mental model.
You also can perceive how
we introduced a strong brand
that we didn't
have before, which
is communicating through
the use of strong colors.
This is also another
element that we're
pushing through
the material design
this year, across
more applications.
And the user, when
faces Play applications,
should feel this is different.
This is a part of
the same family.
This is true for devices.
This is true for web.
Our layouts, we think,
are pretty responsive.
You see in this example
how the same structure
is contained across
multiple devices.
Here, I'm recommended the Batman
movie because a friend of mine
PlusOned it.
And the Batman movie
is larger on devices
like phones or tablets.
But obviously, on
tablets, the card
becomes much bigger,
because we want
to maintain the hierarchy
on larger devices.
And we need to make that card
to be louder than what we would
do on devices like phones,
on smaller screens.
It is modular, and it
tries to adapt to the user.
You see, here, the
system is slightly
moving the face of
this author in order
to be displayed across
smaller screens.
Obviously, we have
more space on tablets.
But again, it is all
responsive, and the type
of display-- the
type of experience
you have-- is pretty
much the same.
It is familiar.
These two are
different applications.
The one to my right is the
Play Books application.
The other one is the store.
But navigating between
two APKs doesn't
have to feel like a very
different experience.
You have ways to still
make your code efficient
and build different
applications,
and still make the
experience to be fluid
when the user is navigating
between one application
to another.
We know we have people
going between consumption
to purchases use
cases very often.
And it is familiar when you
face new Play applications.
Maybe you were the
Play music user.
You want to see how the
Play Book applications work.
We think that you're
going to be welcomed
by a very similar
interface, and you're
going to be feeling at home.
It is responsive.
Obviously, when you
have a larger space,
you get more content
to be displayed.
This is an example that
I particularly like,
where you see that
on my right, we
have a big card that wouldn't
fit on a landscape layout.
So even here, we
maintain the hierarchy,
but the card sort
of adjusts itself
to display the
content to the right.
Again, it should
really feel that as I'm
stretching my windows
on a web browser,
or as I'm changing my device,
almost as if magically
the screen was changing sizes.
All my cards are responsive.
They change in size.
They try to adapt to
whatever the form factor is.
It works cross platform.
It works on web.
It works on Android.
We recently introduced
those, a mobile web UI,
which compared to
what we do on Android,
feels pretty much
the same experience.
It works on iOS, like
I've mentioned before.
These are the Play
Music application
compared between the
two different platforms.
And now, I'm going to give
the controls to Kirill.
He's going to teach
you some coding tricks
and is going to talk more
about some of these principles.
KIRILL: Thank you, Marco.
So what Marco talked about is
this system that I would say
is a pretty efficient
and flexible
in presenting collections.
So if you talk about
what we call a landing
page of the store, where
we want to show you
multiple collections
or items, top charts,
my library in the
music, or search
results in various applications.
And we wanted to extend this
consistency and flexibility
into additional places
where the users interact
with our applications.
So the first one is side
drawer, or navigation drawer,
that was introduced a
year ago at I/O. And we've
been slowly migrating-- a little
bit too slowly, if you will--
we've been migrating our Play
apps to use the side drawer.
And we do want to see
it-- at least, in the Play
suite of apps-- as these, what
we call primary destinations.
We don't want to overload it.
We'd start scrolling and
scrolling and scrolling.
We want to have something
like four, five, or maybe
six primary destinations
within each app.
And then we also put this kind
of secondary action-- settings,
help, and feedback.
And what happens
here is that once you
know that you can swipe to the
left or tap that hamburger icon
and see this navigation, you
will apply that knowledge.
You will be at ease
across multiple apps--
across pretty much all
apps in the Play suite.
From the technical
implementation,
we use the support library.
Drawer layout itself is kind
of the implementation that
allows you to slide
the thing from the left
or from the right
on RTO layouts.
And for integration
with action bar,
the action bar drawer toggle.
And we use a consistent
typography, iconography,
and colors once again to kind
of enforce this consistency.
But what this is
talking about, like
the technical
implementation details.
But what is more
important is that we
do want to create this
consistent navigation
model across all
our applications--
to put the user at ease whenever
he is on Android or on iOS
device or on the web.
Swipey tabs, we use it in
conjunction with the ViewPager.
Sometimes, we do want
to kind of present
this multitab experience.
On the left, if you
go from left to right,
is different views into
your music collection,
in the Play Music app.
Then a single game
in the play games,
just different parts
of the information
that we want to present.
And the two last ones
are various collections
in the Play store app.
So what we want
to have here is we
want to have this
multitab experience.
And we use ViewPager
from the support library
that provides a very
nice, consistent way
that you can swipe left
and right between the tabs.
And we have our own
custom implementation
of the tabs strip that you
can swipe left and right
independently of
the tabs themselves.
And we have this two way
binding to keep in sync, to keep
the selection of the
view pager itself
and the tab strip in sync.
Once again, a little bit
of technical details,
but what is most important
is that once the user knows
that he or she can swipe left
and right the tab strip itself,
that knowledge can be directly
applied to other offerings
from our Play suite of apps.
And this is what happens--
I think it's a nice touch.
If you go from
left to right, you
switch from the About tab
to the My Achievements tab.
And in addition to
the content itself
sliding from left to right, you
can also see in the title strip
the thick, green
underline which signifies
the currently selected tab.
It also slides.
Instead of jumping
immediately, it kind of
slides to the
newly selected tab.
And it also shrinks
or expands based
on the relative widths
of these two tabs.
And these are a little
bit of technical details.
On every scroll event, we
compute the starting x position
and the width of
this underlined.
And we call invalidate
on the title strip.
And then in onDraw, we
draw that green rectangle
or whichever color is needed
for that specific content type.
Once again, we want to be
consistent across our multiple
apps and to kind of enhance
and enforce this consistency.
Hero images are, I would
say, a very big part
of material design.
I think Marco will
agree with me.
It's a very visually
rich and attractive way--
if the images look
good, of course.
It's a very attractive
way to frame your content,
to position your content.
And they would usually go-- I
would say they pretty much have
to go at the top
of your content.
In this sequence of
screenshots from left to right,
you see an album page
in the Play Music app,
a movie page in Play Movies,
a game page in Play Games,
and an article in
Play Newsstand.
And here, a couple
more screenshots
from various places
in the Play Store app.
Matias's profile, an
artist page, TV show page,
and what we call an
editorial collection.
So what you see here
is this hero image
that goes edge to
edge horizontally,
and also kind of goes
into the action bar.
So what we want to do
with this action bar
is instead of this
solid block of color
that kind of hangs on
top of your content
and is kind of a
little bit distracting,
what we do here is we extend the
hero image into the action bar.
We effectively remove
the action bar background
while still showing the action
bar title and your navigation
icons or our action bar icons.
From the implementation
point of view,
you request this window feature.
And you call drawable set alpha
on your action bar background
drawable.
And that's it.
The hero image, or
effectively, your content,
will extend into the action bar.
And that hero image,
you should make it not
have black bars on top
and bottom, because that
would look kind of ugly.
And if you have these
attractive images,
it's going to be a very
nice experience-- not only
across Play, but you
can see how we conformed
the specific part of
the material design.
And in this particular example,
all the images that I've shown
were kind of dark, which
provided a nice contrast
to the white title
and the white icons.
But you do want to create
kind of translucent black
protection,
translucent gradient,
along the top edge
of your hero image,
so that if your
hero image is light,
you still have enough contrast
to show those foreground
elements on your action bar.
Once you do start
scrolling it, we
do it consistently
across Play, and I'm
pretty sure that it applies
well beyond Play, once you start
using hero images in
your applications.
Once you do start
scrolling and you kind of
have these individual items,
stacks, and maybe check marks,
check boxes, spinners, kind of
scrolling below the action bar,
you should make it opaque.
You should crossfade
it to fully opaque.
Otherwise, there's
too much noise
when text is
crawling behind text.
And from the
implementation perspective,
you register a scroll listener
on your main container.
It can be list view,
scroll view, recycler view.
Or if you have a custom
container, you do that.
You compute the alpha
of the action bar
background drawable based
on how far you've scrolled
and how tall the image is.
And you call setAlpha.
Another nice touch is deployed
consistently across all Play
applications, once again, to
kind of enforce this feeling
that we are all part of this
bigger suite of applications,
is parallax scrolling, which
also extended into the material
design, into what we
call the z-axis, where
you have one or two elements on
the screen that feel that they
are positioned a little
bit farther away from you
or a little bit closer to you.
So what happens if you
look at my face over there,
and this stone arch?
From left to right,
as I start scrolling,
the vertical alignment
of these two images
is a little bit different
from frame to frame.
So what happens is that we
make the hero image scroll
a little bit slower than
the rest of the content.
Specifically, across
Play applications,
we do it at half the rate, just
to be consistent, once again,
across all our offerings.
But this is not
something set in stone.
You can experiment
with different values.
It just gives a little
bit more interest.
It adds a little bit
more flare to what
happens when you start
scrolling this content.
In the same scroll listener
that you have in the screen,
in your fragment,
in your activity,
what you do is--
what we do-- is let's
say you scrolled it
up by 200 pixels.
What we do, the hero
image itself, of course,
is scrolled as part
of this main column.
And we push it
down by 100 pixels.
So what happens is that
while the rest of the content
is scrolling at a certain
speed, the hero image
is scrolling-- or appears to be
scrolling at half that speed.
It appears to be a little
bit farther away from you,
creating this kind of z offset--
that it appears to be somewhere
there in the background,
while the main content here
is closer to me.
We also have this interaction
between hero images
and the side drawer.
We strongly feel
that side drawers
should be this place
where you navigate
between primary
destinations in your app.
And so when you open
the side drawer,
we want to kind of de-emphasize
the rest of the content.
We want to kind of push it
a little bit away from you.
You get it for free
from the side drawer,
with this kind of
translucent black overlay,
that you can see
that there's kind
of a shade drawn on top
of the main content.
In addition to that, we also
crossfade the action bar
to fully opaque.
So what happens here is you can
see that the hero image kind
of goes even farther
away from you,
and the content also
appears to kind of
be pushed away from you.
And the drawer kind of moves
a little bit closer to you.
Once again, we want to be
consistent across all Play
apps.
And this is what we do.
This is a specific
example in the Play store,
but we do it everywhere
in the Play apps.
And a little bit of
the technical details.
On every slide event, we compute
the alpha of the background
drawable of the
action bar, based
on how far along you are
in this sliding motion
and how far vertically you
are in your column of content.
And now, back to Marco.
MARCO: Thank you.
So let's recap what we saw
and what we learn from it.
This was the state
of Play in 2012.
A lot of different applications,
different among themselves,
different in the way
they were working
on web versus Android devices.
Our goals were to
create consistency,
to have efficiency in the
way we design our layouts
and we implement them, and
to be able to display content
dynamically.
This is where we
ended up, or this
is where we ended
up until today.
We have work going on and a lot
of things coming, of course.
But you can see
what we achieved was
to create a consistency and a
strong brand-- what we believe
being a strong brand
that differentiated
our applications from other
applications out there.
They work across web,
with mobile versions,
with the full, dynamic
population of content.
We have the same
layouts working on iOS,
respecting the iOS pattern,
but also bringing in the Google
touch and the Google Play touch.
And that's how we think people
should perceive our content.
It's just about content.
It's about colors,
about photography.
It doesn't matter which
device you're using.
What are the results?
Certainly, we increased
the speed of execution.
Before, we were spending
a lot of time getting
the same features in
different applications--
so between web and devices--
while at this point,
we're very fast in defining
how things should work
then make them work everywhere.
Obviously, when you
support more platform,
you need more developers.
But we didn't increase largely
the number of designers,
even if we started
having applications
on iOS and other platforms
that we didn't support before.
And we also saw more
collaboration among designers.
We can have more people
focusing on a problem
and tackling it and doing it
very well-- like introducing
a new pattern and scaling
it across all applications,
rather than having a
lot of designers working
in their own desk to
solve a little problem
for the little,
small application.
So what is next?
KIRILL: So we have four
additional sessions
that I would recommend
you if you're
interested in seeing where we're
going with material design.
And specifically,
at 11 o'clock--
I know we don't usually
talk about what's
next in the pipeline.
But if you do want to see
what Marco's team is doing,
exploring, bringing Google
Play further into the material
world-- if you had to
select one session,
go to the 11 o'clock
session in this room.
I really highly recommend it.
I'm not going to say
anything more beyond that.
And can you go to next slide?
So we have the Android
design guidelines
available at this URL.
And in addition, yesterday,
we've published a kind of cross
Google or material
design guidelines
at google.com/design.
Your feedback is
highly appreciated.
This QR code or this short link.
And additional sessions
from this year's I/O
and the previous
year's conferences
is available on the
Google Developers channel.
And here, we would like to
thank you for your time today.
You can find us on Google+.
And thank you for your time.
MARCO: Thank you.
KIRILL: And we have 12 minutes,
34 seconds for questions.
There are two mics, over
here, and left and right.
Thank you, once again.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCO: Questions?
No questions?
Do you want to go to the mic?
AUDIENCE: Uh, hello.
Mehmet from Chicago,
Content Direct.
I have a question about
the side drawer menu.
What do you think about
categorized side drawer menus?
From your design, you have
each menu element on its own.
But some of the apps use a
more categorized approach,
where they say these are
your home side menus,
and these are your different
playlists under a playlist tab.
So they are more categorized.
What do you think
about this approach?
MARCO: Can I take this question?
Yeah?
I don't think there's
one rule to fit them all.
On Play, specifically,
we decided
to only expose the main areas.
There are other
applications that
expose a more granular list.
I think it's important, if you
have a series of applications,
to be consistent
within yourselves.
So if we had one Play
application going
one way, another Play
application going another way,
that probably
would be confusing.
But there isn't
really a rule for what
to put in the side nav
in terms of destination.
There is a rule,
which is we should
try not to put actions
in the side nav.
We should respect the overflow
menu and the actions being
exposed in the action bar
or in the viewing itself,
and use the side nav
purely for destinations.
But whether the destination
is singular playlist,
or it is the whole
playlist area as a whole,
there isn't really
a special rule.
I think it's up to the
designer and to the developer
to define based on
their experience.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KIRILL: Yeah, and you
don't want to end up
with what happened in the late
'90s in desktop applications,
when they kind of had this
Tools menu-- where they just
threw random items
that didn't have
any connection with each other,
because there was no better
place, if you will,
to throw them.
So the side drawer is not
supposed to be a junk drawer.
MARCO: Yeah, something you can
do is also create hierarchy.
As you see in our
side navigation,
we tried to create some
hierarchy between Settings
and Send Feedback
and things like that,
versus the main
destinations, which
we tried to highlight more.
KIRILL: Yeah, with
typography and sizing.
AUDIENCE: Since we're
talking side drawers,
I've seen a couple
usability studies that
say there's about a 50% drop off
in discoverability of the side
drawer menu items versus tabs.
Do you have any experience
or additional data points
in that area?
MARCO: Mhm.
You know, I definitely
agree with that.
And I don't think it's new-- I
don't think you need a genius
to write those sorts of
articles, because clearly,
if you hide items
inside a button,
you're going to
have less engagement
than if those
items were exposed.
This is also true if you have
actions in the overflow menu,
rather than being exposed.
They will have less engagement.
So obviously, yes,
this is an heuristic.
If you see, the way we tackle
this on our applications
is that the side nav, yes,
does have all the destinations
you can go to.
But we also expose,
most of the time,
those destinations
in the main view.
So for example, if
you're in the store,
we do have a people section.
But if you have friends, we
also expose an explore cluster
in your main destination.
Or if you see what
we do on Newsstand,
we'll have introduced a
bunch of different tabs
for you to read all the
different sections you have.
And in the side nav,
really what we leave
is A, a clear and consistent
way to see what we have,
despite what is present
in the main navigation,
in the main page.
But also, destinations that
we think are less important
and they shouldn't have
a lot of engagement.
So for instance, if you
have a destination which
is about library
management, it's
fine to be in the side nav,
because how many times do you
go to a destination
to delete an album
or to do other things with this?
But certainly, your main
experience is where you land,
and there are ways to
connect the dots, even
in the same main
experience, without having
to go through the
side navigation.
The side navigation can almost
be a tree of all the things
that you have within
your application.
KIRILL: All right,
looks like we're done.
MARCO: OK.
If you want to talk
to us, we're going
to stay here for
seven more minutes.
KIRILL: Yeah, I'll be
out in the hallway.
MARCO: Cool, thank
you very much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]